[Musique]
la première pierre de l'espace ludique
paysager de Moulins Joly à la possession
a été posée ce jeudi 13 octobre l'espace
accueillera également skatepark activité
très prisée des jeunes
ainsi qu'il sera végétalisé avec pas
moins de 4000 plans remettre la nature
au cœur des villes une volonté du
département avec son plan un million
d'arbres
c'est un espace qui va être dédié aux
jeunes de la possession mais aussi aux
familles avec une aire de pique-nique
avec un espace qui va être planté avec
beaucoup de d'endémic 4000 arbres au
total endémique et indigènes et aussi
parcours de santé berger et rucher
communal bref vraiment un endroit où il
fera bon vivre dans ce quartier de
moulin Joly cet espace est financé à
hauteur de 3 millions 200000 euros par
le Conseil départemental un projet qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre du pacte de
solidarité territoriale deuxième
génération la volonté du département et
d'accompagner le dynamisme des
territoires de la Réunion et
la possession aujourd'hui nous propose
un projet qui
exprime ce dynamisme la possession ne va
on le sait à une croissance
démographique une des plus importantes
de la Réunion et cette jeunesse qui
pousse réclamée cette nouvelle
installation le PST est un outil
magnifique très dynamique qui permet
justement aux communes de pouvoir très
rapidement réaliser des projets
magnifiques comme on voit ici à la
possession le skatepark sera livré en
décembre 2022 le reste des travaux
s'achèvera à la mi-203
[Musique]